[MUSIC PLAYING]
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: You
guys know who I am,
my name is Kelsey
Hightower, I work at Google.
I specialize in Kubernetes,
Google Container Engine.
And this talk, we're
going to talk about some
of the moving pieces
when most people think
about the container, or
the container development
cloud native workflow.
So I'm not going to give you a
very prescriptive, end-to-end
deployment mythology,
but I am going
to talk about the workflows,
especially the ones that I use,
and I've seen some
people use in the wild.
I'm also going to incorporate
some of the new things you've
heard about.
So Google Container Builder.
How many people have heard of
the Google Container Builder?
How many people are
good at using it?
Me either.
So this is, we're in
for some excitement.
I just finished these demos
like seven minutes ago,
so I hope they work well.
I'm going to need
help, so anything
that I do, any demo that
works, just kept loudly.
Are you guys in for that?
All right, so the
agenda today, we're
going to talk about cloud native
applications and what they mean
and what I think
about them, right.
So I know a lot of
people are trying
to take their
existing applications,
some people call them
legacy applications,
and move them into a cloud.
Is that a cloud
native application?
It's just your app
running in the cloud.
There's a difference.
OK so we're going to try to talk
about the things and properties
that make an app called native.
And I don't think
there's a huge gap,
but there's some
work you got to do.
And we're going to talk about
building container images.
So Google Container
Builder attempts
to allow you to build
images without them
running on your laptop.
Now my workflow, I typically
don't involve containers
at all.
I do all the development
on my local laptop.
I just use local tools, I run
post-scripts on my laptop,
or my SQL on my
laptop, and I only
use containers
for the last mile.
For packaging and deployment.
So I don't really get
into those workflows,
so now I actually have a
different tool I can use.
And then the last
one is that I hear
a lot is, how do I manage
multiple environments?
How many of you are running
Kubernetes in production?
Just raise your hand
like you're lying,
looks really cool
for the camera.
How many people are sharing
that cluster for development?
Ooh!
Man, you guys are going
to be on the news.
I'm looking for
that post mortem.
You know it's coming.
We're going to talk
about some patterns
that I've seen for doing
Kubernetes responsively.
OK.
Now this isn't the only
way of doing things,
but something for
you to think about.
So the first thing to talk about
is a cloud native application.
How many people have
built one of these?
These are the same people
running production and DEV
in the same cluster.
I'm worried about this
whole cloud native thing.
So here's what I think
about cloud native, pretty
straightforward to me.
It builds on top of the
whole 12 factor thing.
So if you've heard of
the 12 factor manifesto,
I boil that down into
writing applications
that the couple themselves
from the environment.
OK.
So that made it really
easy for people to adopt.
Paas platforms, like
App Engine, move around
and adopt new platforms
that come out.
So a lot of people
that have already
bitten off the 12
factor pattern,
found it really easy
to adopt something
like Docker or Kubernetes,
because their application was
already self-contained
and did a few things that
let them adopt a new platform.
Now the other one is
scale horizontally.
So this is one where I think
when people enter the container
world, especially something like
Kubernetes for the first time,
they're trying to build their
applications the same way they
did on the virtual
machine, and that's
just not how Kubernetes
is designed, right.
The idea here is that you
will specify your workload
in these units that
could scale horizontally.
And then honestly, we
want the applications
to be much smarter.
How many people are still
writing Nagios scripts?
That's my OPS people.
You hate your
developers, don't you?
I'm not writing
any more scripts,
like build it into the app.
So I think cloud
native applications
will expose health checks.
They'll do things like
application tracing.
They'll have all these
metrics built in.
And then it needs
to be operable,
and we'll see what that
means in a second here.
Now the other caveat
is that this isn't just
for micro services.
A lot of people
are like, oh we're
going to adopt micro
services and Kubernetes
and cloud native
at the same time.
That just doesn't work out well.
If you have a
monolith application,
some of these
patterns still apply,
and we're going to check out
one of my example applications
in a moment here.
So I'm going to do a
demo of this application.
So this is going to be a
little GIF builder application,
I'm going to show you a
little GIF that we have.
So Google has all
these little doodles.
Here's one of my favorite
doodles from Google.
So I'm going to open
this with my browser.
Maybe you've seen this
doodle before, maybe not.
So this guy is serious business.
OK this is from
this fruit Olympics.
And there's like
1,000 images here,
and we need to remix
this a little bit.
So I want to make this
a little bit easier.
So what I did here was export
all these individual images,
and I'm going to send it to
my own little service here.
So first thing
I'm going to do is
look at all the
images that are built
from this particular thing.
Here's all the individual
images that it takes
to make that particular thing.
I'm just going to
take a few of them
and send it to my own service.
Now when I look at the
design of my service,
I'm doing a couple of things.
One, I want to make sure that
my application can run anywhere
in the globe.
Even startups, or even
small companies now,
have this notion
from their customers
that their app should
run anywhere and scale
across multiple regions.
Now this is super
hard, especially
if you're trying to run
with data stores yourself.
So for this demo, I'm using
a cloud native database,
we call it Spanner.
And Spanner's going to
let me just off lift
all of the thinking about
distributed transactions,
all the SQL stuff
to Spanner itself.
So I'll be using
that in this demo.
And I'm also going
to avoid POSIX.
If you're a system
administrator,
POSIX and Kubernetes
don't go together.
I see people try
it all the time.
They take things
like NFS and try
to run it throughout
a Kubernetes cluster.
How many people have dealt
with NFS and Kubernetes?
Cap if you like it.
No claps.
It's hard.
So in this case, I'm going
to use an object store.
So when I process
these images, I
want to store them on
Google Cloud Storage.
So here we're going to
start our application.
So this little command,
I'm going to build my app.
Do this one on port8080.
I'm going to define a DEV
bucket, a Spanner database.
How many people have played
with Spanner already?
Oh, awesome, three people.
We need to have more than that.
So here we're going
to run our app.
So the first thing we
want to do is build it.
So go build.
So this is all live.
I'm hoping it works.
Please work.
Let's actually install it,
so I can be in my path.
Remember if anything
works, you guys go crazy.
All right so we're
going to run this.
All right so we're listening.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is just use curl to post images
to that running a local host.
And we'll see what the
results look like, 8080.
So if this works from a laptop,
we'll be writing into Spanner,
and then we'll actually
be storing images
on cloud storage.
Buddy, I don't know.
I don't know if you
improved my odds.
Oh, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, don't be
clapping until it works.
Let's see, did we remix it?
[APPLAUSE]
OK, so this is our cloud
native application now.
So this thing needs the
cloud, obviously, to work.
And once you have
internet access,
we can actually
deploy our stuff.
So let's look at where all
this stuff is stored, OK.
So let's poke around here and
see what our application is
doing, to make sure we can
replicate it when we deploy it
to Kubernetes.
So the first thing we want
to look at here is Spanner.
So what I'm doing
inside of Spanner,
I'm giving it a
set of credentials,
and all the libraries
to access Spanner
just assume that you have
your service account in path,
and I'll show you how to deploy
that in a tool like Kubernetes.
So here, we'll click around.
And I've been writing
events to our Dev cluster.
And we come over here and
we look at our events.
Somebody's like, man, I just
want to talk about Spanner.
I know,
Right, so here we'll make sure
that we see our events inside.
OK.
So we'll run the query.
All right, so we see our events
are being writed in here,
and I'm just dropping in
the path to our actual image
that I was just sharing.
And then I'm storing
all the images inside
of Google Cloud storage, so now
my app is free to move around.
So now we have this
cloud native application,
we need to move on to
talk about packaging it.
Now the other thing that
I do is, it took a while
to run that, right?
And we talked about
built in monitoring
for your application.
So one thing I like to do
is use tracing regardless,
and annotate and
trace everything
I can to know what's
going on in my app.
So this is a stacked
driver trace.
I'm just going to click on one
of these, one of my trace's
that I had before.
And what you can
start to see here
is I import a few lines of code.
And now I can see the
span of time that's
taking from my actual request.
You can see here about 500 some
odd milliseconds was uploading
those images to
Google Cloud Storage
so I can do the processing.
And then logging the
event to Spanner,
so all the round trips and
formatting the particular thing
that needed to go into Spanner.
So deploying an application
like this out of the box,
it makes it really easy
for me to figure out
what's going on without
digging into the source code,
all right.
So this is what I
mean by cloud native,
and there's other
ways you can do this,
but I think having these
properties out of a box
is the things that
take us from 12 factor
and move a step forward
can run in any environment
with this kind of visibility.
All right, so let's
move onto the next step.
So that's your
cloud native thing.
So now let's get to
this container builder.
So we have our app.
And the price of admission
for these platforms
is it needs to be in
a container image.
And I use to keep Docker
for Mac on my laptop
just so I can build these images
and push them to a registry.
But really what I want is
just some service or something
else that can do it.
Really when I check in my
code, I want it to happen.
How many people are building
containers on their laptop.
Keep your hand up if you're
pushing to production
from that same image.
Whoo!
That person is dangerous.
Pushing content images
from your laptop, it works.
I don't recommend it.
So we have something like
Google Cloud Builder.
So the goal here
is that it's going
to be a fully managed
service, it has a rest API.
The idea here is that you can
connect to it from other tools,
other CI systems.
And then here it
also support things
like build triggers, tags,
or other custom build steps.
And the idea here is that
it has full integration
into Google Container registry.
Now this is the same service
that we use for App Engine
Flex, cloud functions.
Those services use this
underneath the covers,
and you'll also
have access to it.
And you also can use
your own custom scripts,
and we'll walk through
what that looks like here.
So let's jump over to
the container builder.
So now that we have this
binary up and running,
we can verify that it works.
We want to build it now.
OK so the first thing
you're going to need
is one of these Cloud
build like EML files.
So what we see here is
basically a list of containers.
So you have a list
of steps, just
like any other build system.
And the first
thing we want to do
is specify the
container we want to use
for this particular step.
So in this case, I'm just
going to use one of the default
images from the Cloud Builder.
Team.
So this has go link and it,
has the latest version of go,
go1.8 is in there.
So all I have to do is specify
the container I want to use.
That's going to mount my source
code into a workspace directory
and then run the
commands that I specify.
So here I'm just going to say
go install, which will then
produce a binary that
will be available for me
in the workspace directory
for the next step.
So now we kind of get
this pipeline thing going.
And the next step
is I'm just going
to use a Docker container.
And what I want to do here
is just call Docker build.
Now what this will
assume here is
that I have a Docker build
file in my workspace.
So if I look at this
Docker build file,
you see here that I'm adding
the binary that comes out,
so it's out of my go path.
There'll be this GIF maker
binary, I'm just copying it,
and that's the only thing there.
And I'm just using
Alpine as a base image.
Some people will
say, hey why are you
not using the scratch image?
Normally when I'm deploying
things like to production,
sometimes I do need to get
in there and troubleshoot.
And not having some kind
of base image there the has
some utilities or the
ability to add utilities,
makes it a little bit
harder to troubleshoot,
especially if you're
in production.
So I usually use a very small,
minimal image like this.
So given that if we
were to push this,
we should create this particular
image from our source code.
So we'll run that command now.
Now I'm going to cheat
and rely on my history
to know what command that is.
So what we want to do
here is take that config,
take our current
context, and push it up
to container builder.
I don't want to know your
data plan is going to be but,
it's going to be a
little expensive.
All right so what
we're doing now
is tying up all the
content, so we're pushing it
to container builder.
And this is actually a
pretty good idea because now
that we're not pulling down
all those Docker containers
on my laptop, because
your data plan would
be just totally screwed
if I did that, we're
doing all this on the other
side, on the server side.
So all the logs here are
available as Stackdriver
logging.
So what you have here now is all
the steps are coming out here.
And if everything works,
what you'll see is we'll
have our resulting image
pushed to container registry
automatically.
Now the tool is smart enough
to use your service credentials
or anything that you have
set up in IM so it pushes
to the right place,
and once it's there,
it's available for me to use.
Now if I were to pop over
to the container builder
UI, which is part of the
container registry UI,
we click over here.
And we also have all
your build history,
so here you can kind of
drill in to all of your logs
to see what happened.
You can go into each
individual step if you want to.
And this is where you
can kind of log and see
things that are working.
And now that we have this
particular image available,
we can look at our
container registry
and we'll see that the
image should be there.
So let's find it here.
GIF maker.
And we'll see that
it's tagged there.
So at this point, we should be
able to push our application
to our development environment.
So let's talk a little bit
about the registry before we do.
So the container registry,
the goal of this,
and why did we build this, why
not just use the Docker hub?
Well number one, people
want their content images
to be accessible
and make them fast.
So having Google
container registry
means that your images are
stored inside the same cloud
infrastructure.
It's backed by
Google Cloud Storage,
so all your images
are replicated,
you don't have to worry
about those things,
and it's private by default. So
it has integration to IAM, so
all the things you're using
for the rest of your resources,
we piggyback on top
of those things.
Some of the other
things, the team
is really up to date on the
image format we support.
So Docker v2 image
format and SOCI
continues to make progress,
that's the open container image
format, we'll have
support for that too.
Vulnerability scanning
will be built in.
So if you look at some of
the command line tooling,
you start to see hints
of that in our UI.
And the goal here is that
we'll start by notifying you
if there's any vulnerabilities
found in your image,
maybe inside of your base image.
Tools will get more advanced
and start doing static analysis
to tell you, hey, you're
using a vulnerable library,
you might want to update
that and do a rebuild.
And it's backed by Google Cloud
storage like we saw before.
Now when you're using this, you
can definitely use the command
line to do most things.
So you can list tags
for all your images,
and here's where you would
see any vulnerability
reports that show up.
So here's our first
image that we pushed.
You can list all the
images you have there.
Even though this seems
like a simple thing,
most container registries
do not have a way for you
to figure out what the tags
are, you have to go to the GUI
and drill down.
So having this on the command
line is super easy for me
to figure out which
I want to play with
and what I want to deploy.
So all this is kind of built
in, all this is integrated.
So so far we've talked about
building a cloud native
app, this idea that
we want to build it,
but we don't want to build
things from our laptop,
we want something
like a build trigger.
OK, so now that I have this
application, what I really
want to do is set
up a build trigger
that will automatically
build this app,
but not on every check in.
I actually experimented
with having a container
built on every check in.
How many people have
run out of space before?
That's what that feels like.
OK?
So what I found
works a little bit
better is build the
containers on tags.
So when I tag something,
that's when I want
my build to actually happen.
So here I'll go to my build
triggers, and I can define one.
So here's a build trigger,
and the UI is pretty nice,
you can go through and
pick particular hosting
repositories, like GitHub.
And here, I want to have
a tag trigger a build,
and when that tag shows up
matching my regular expression,
I want it to run the commands
in the cloudbuild.yaml.
So we need to make one
modification for this
to actually work.
So we want to, instead of hard
coding the tag number there,
we want to actually have it
replaced with the actual tag
on the repository.
So I'll just do like that
whole cooking show thing
and then let's take a look.
So we'll grab the tag name
and make that our image name
and have it trigger
the build that way.
So we'll push this up
and then we'll tag it.
So here we'll just
do git status.
Man, look at all
that other stuff.
I don't know if I
should check it in.
How many people just do git
add don't even look at it
You're that guy like,
hey man, who checked
in their PlayStation games?
Like, oh, my bad dude.
I'll fix it.
All right so what we'll
do here is, who cares.
I think we just add it all.
I really want to
see what that is.
That looks safe, I think.
All right, let's just do that.
So let's just do
this thing here.
So what you should do always
is just blindly do that.
And then the worst thing
is when people do this.
Updating stuff.
It's like, dude, how am I
going to co-review that?
Yeah you updated stuff,
but it's not right.
Just take it as is, dude.
All right, so now we
have this new thing up.
Ideally it should still build.
So the next thing you want
to do is tag it, so git tag.
And then we'll call
it 0.0.1 And then
we'll say git
push, origin, tags.
What?
Oh.
All right, so we
push this there.
We should trigger a build.
Please beta, be working.
So the first warning
is when you log in
and it says this at the top.
You need to think about
that a little bit.
So we come over here.
Uh-oh.
A build is triggering.
Do we get some logs?
I'm so happy on the inside right
now, you guys don't even know.
It's fast, too.
So now we have the 1.0 image
based on the build trigger.
So now my workflow could
be, build my application,
test locally--
you might want to answer that.
Ask them if they have
any internet access.
Push it locally, and then
once I tag the repository,
I now have this automatic
bill trigger that I
don't have to think about.
So all of this is
kind of built in,
so automatically in
Google Container registry,
so at this point, I'm ready
to start consuming that image
inside of my container cluster.
All right, so we have our
build trigger in place,
so let's move on
to the next step.
So this is kind of what we want
out of this registry system.
We want to be fully automated.
And again, the design here
is that you can hook up
other tools to do this as well.
All right, this guy's
still working out,
he's probably tired.
So I want to talking about
Google Container Engine.
If you haven't used GKE, the
best way to think about it
is we take open-source
Kubernetes.
We don't modify it
in any way, but we
do glue in all the
Google services,
like the logging from
Stackdriver, logging
for Stackdriver, we do
monitoring from Stackdriver,
we pull the metrics
from the cluster itself.
We take care of all the
upgrades and scaling
the nose if you
turn on that option.
One of the best features I'd
like is that IAM integration.
So anything that you use from
QCTL from your credentials,
once we have the
detailed R back,
that will be integrated into
the alpha announcement we
had today with custom IM roles.
You'll be able to map that
to your Kubernetes roles
and be able to control access.
And then it's also easy to
manage multiple clusters
at a time.
Now the reason for
this is we want
you to focus on using
Kubernetes and not managing it.
Now having all of
this integration also
leads to the next
thing, which is managing
development environments.
Now this is where it gets real
confusing for most people.
The first thing
people do when they
get a Kubernetes cluster is give
everyone in the company QCTL.
This guy's laughing his
ass off becuase that
leads to a bunch of problems.
Number one by default,
most people are giving out
admin credentials, so
people are adding things,
deleting things that
they shouldn't delete.
So we've got to talk about
a better way of sharing
a cluster in development.
And I do like the
idea of self-service.
You do not want to operate
on a ticketing system
to get someone to deploy
something in Kubernetes.
We made it far too easy to
use the cluster to do that.
So if you're in OPS, the
way you think about this
is to provide a sandbox
for testing, and playing
with these configs until they
get it right in production.
So what we want to do is talk
about how to share a cluster.
Now I think name spaces
is one of the best ways
to share a cluster
inside of Kubernetes.
You can give a namespace
to a whole team,
you can give a namespace
to individual developers
and let them go wild
in that little sandbox.
But the key, once you
issue that namespace,
is you want to use quotas
to limit what they can use
in that particular namespace.
You want to prevent
mistakes, right.
We're not trying to defend
against malicious users
but we want to make sure
people don't accidentally
consume too much and give
direct access to this.
So if you haven't
used name spaces,
we're going to flip over
and show you how people
are managing these things.
So one thing people
are doing is they
have a git repository that holds
a lot of the infrastructure
stuff.
If you come from a
infrastructurist code
background, you're
kind of familiar
with this particular model.
Here, this is where
restoring our configfs.
So what we want to do here
is we'll have a dev setup.
So as a cluster administrator,
I want to prep these name spaces
and put quotas in place.
As a developer, I'm
assuming my credentials
that are given to me are scoped
to that particular namespace,
and I can just push
that namespace and deal
with the resources that I have.
Now one thing is important
you have to remember,
the name space and
a single cluster
is shared across all the nodes.
So you're not
going to limit them
on what nodes their
workloads can land on,
so you want to put
that quota in place
to make sure that you're
sharing resources effectively.
So the first thing I
want to do is make sure
that I'm using
the right cluster.
So for those that don't know
kubectl, the Kubernetes command
line tool, supports
multiple clusters,
you can just squish
between them.
So here we're going to use
kubectl, config, use-context,
and then we're going to say dev.
So now I'm pointing
to my dev cluster.
And here I'm going to
create a namespace.
There's this really annoying
developer hightower, this guy,
and he's just rambunctious,
thinks he knows everything.
So I'm going to give
him his own name space,
and he can go wild in
that particular namespace.
So as a cluster administrator,
I'll say kubectl apply,
and I'll create
this new namespace.
So once this
namespace is in place,
before I hand out
credentials, I'm
also going to put a
quota in place here.
All right, so this quota
will allow only one service.
Probably one of the most
important quota things,
people start creating
a bunch of services,
you're going to have
a bunch of public IPs
and you're going to be spending
a lot of money at Google.
That's probably a good idea,
so probably up that number
if you want to.
We're going to limit
it to three pods,
and then we're going to
limit the amount of CPU
and other resources
that they can require.
So here, we're just going
to do an apply here as well.
All right so now our
namespace is set up.
Now we're able to give our
credentials to the developer.
So what we want to do here
is limit what we give them
by default. I'm just
going to switch contexts,
but when you give
out your configs,
you can actually put them
in a specific context,
give them a
namespace, so it just
defaults to the right thing.
Right, and then maybe
limit their credentials
on what they can switch to.
So here we'll say kubectl,
config, use-context.
And here I'll just use
the khightower context.
All right, so once I'm in
the khightower context,
I now have my own environment
and sandbox to play in.
So I say kubectl
get pods, hopefully
there's nothing running.
And then also we can
look at our quota.
So kubectl describe quota.
And we can see the limits
that are put in place.
So at this point, that's
all I have to work with.
So I'm going to deploy
that application
that we had earlier.
So here I'm just going
to update my deployment.
So in my Dev, I check
in my Kubernetes configs
next to my application.
If you're running things like
mini cube on your laptop,
it will give you a one
node Kubernetes cluster.
It's a good idea to
test out these configfs
before you push them up and
push them to other higher
level environments.
So here, what I'm going to do
is look at my Kubernetes config
for my deployment object.
And you'll notice a few
things here for configuration.
Here you can see that
I'm pointing at the image
that we just built
from that tag.
Down here, I'm having
my configs separated.
A lot of people struggle
with this idea of where do
I put my configuration files?
I recommend you do not put
them inside of your image.
Do not build a new image to
deploy to an environment that
has your configs in it.
Kubernetes makes it
too easy for you just
to have your configs
parked outside.
Inside of Kubernetes, in this
case, we're using config maps.
Here we're specifying
the database
we want to connect to,
the bucket we want to use,
and the project ID that
we need to consume.
Now my application
doesn't necessarily
take environment
variables, so I'm
able to reference those
config maps in my flags
by using this method
here where you
can refer to
environment variables
and Kubernetes will substitute
them before they're actually
deployed.
Now here's the
other bit that you
need to think about when you're
managing these environments.
Even in Dev and
production, you want
to know how your
application performs
with these kind of constraints.
When I talk to customers,
this is the first thing
that they fall down on.
Most people are used to having
the whole VM or bare metal
machine at their disposal
and they've never
been capped before.
You take that application and
you move it into an environment
where we start
enforcing cgroups,
it starts behaving weird, right?
They just say the
app is slow now.
Right, of course it
is, we're throttling
how much CPU you can use.
So you need to start
measuring these things,
I would say even at
the lower environments
or even on your laptop.
So make sure you put in the
limits and request in place.
And here we're mounting
in our config maps.
Also my service
account that I need
to connect to all
those resources,
just like we saw on
the command line.
And the other thing that
I do in my Dev environment
is I also check in my
configuration options.
So if you look here, I'm going
to connect the Dev bucket
because that's the thing
that I have access to.
I'm going to connect to the
Dev database inside of Spanner.
I'm also going to use my
personal project ID, right?
So as a developer,
I know I'm pointing
to the right namespace.
So what we'll do here,
say kubectl apply dash f.
And then I'm going to say
this whole Kubernetes folder.
So most people don't know,
you can actually just
point to a whole folder and
it'll take all the configs
and push them to Kubernetes
at the same time,
so I don't have to
do them one by one.
Now if I push this
up, we should now
have our configuration files
and credentials all in place,
and our deployment there.
So let's see if it's
actually running.
It is running, as I expect
it with lots of confidence.
So with this running, I
can now connect to it.
So beforehand, I created a
service, kubectl, get svc,
and then we can actually
look at our quota
again to see how much
we're actually taking up.
So that actually cost me
about half of my CPU limit,
so I'm not going to
deploy much more here.
So what happens if you
do accidentally try
to scale this out a little bit?
So let's try it really
quick, so kubectl.
We're going to scale
the deployment object.
So I'm going to
scale my deployment
inside of Kubernetes.
And this is going to be called
GIF maker, replicas equal 3.
And then what we'll do is we'll
also watch for some events,
so we actually see what's
going on in Kubernetes.
Kubectl, get events, --watch.
So here's all the events that
are coming out of our cluster.
So we're about to
kick off this command
and we're going to
see what happens.
You want to observe
the behavior.
So I'm going to ask
for three of these.
And as I asked for three of
these, we get some errors here.
Right?
So we'll cut this.
And we'll see that some of
them fail because we actually
hit our quota.
So we're going to end
up with this only two
out of three pods.
And the deployment
controller behind the scenes
will continue to try to
create the third pod, hoping
that quota will show up
to allow us to do it.
But in the meanwhile,
we're going
to continue to hit
this error and we
won't be able to
actually use any more
inside this
particular namespace.
If I say kubctl get pods,
we'll only have two running.
If I look at my quota, we can
see that I'm out of quota,
and at this point we
can have a conversation
with the administrator,
or you can
be monitoring the events
that are coming out
of Kubernetes to say, hey, we
have a namespace that seems
to be needing more resources.
And if the cluster
isn't fully utilized,
you can come back here and add
resources to that particular
quota,or to that
particular cluster.
So we can bump that
up a little bit.
It takes a moment for
this thing to resolve,
but we can go ahead
and do it now.
So we'll say kubectl
compute resources.
And we'll bump some of
this up, we;ll say, hey,
let's go ahead and
give you four here,
we'll give you eight
here, and those are fine.
And then we'll
say kubectl apply.
So this is me as a
cluster administrator,
I'm noticing that there
needs to be something fixed.
Apply-f, compute resources.
So at this point,
there's more quota inside
of that particular namespace.
We see the limits
have been risen.
So at this point, the
deployment controller
will try and try
until it finds room
to actually run this workload.
So let's see what's happening.
Kubectl get pods.
All right, so this
will take a moment.
And then when it realizes that
it will work, it will show up.
So we're just going to let
that continue in the background
as we move on to production.
So we have one
more main use case
that I want to show you
when dealing with this,
and also how container
builder can help us even
for the production situation.
So look at this really quick.
This guy's still
doing his thing.
So for production environments.
This is where I think you should
just use a dedicated cluster.
One, you don't want to
upgrade Kubernetes and try out
new features.
And the last thing
you want to do
is upgrade Kubernetes
because you
want to use some new feature
for Dev, to experiment
and take down production.
All right?
You do not want to fill
out that post mortem.
There's no reason to.
The idea here is
that the configs
you write in one
environment ideally
can move to the
next environment,
because all you
have to change is
the config settings between
different clusters or name
spaces.
And we saw the resource
quotas and limits.
There's another
thing that I want
to show you that I actually
don't have on a slide
that I think is important,
is like you want real health
checks.
So when we look at our
production environments,
and we'll go over here,
we want to make sure
that you're actually
using things like health
checks inside of this.
So in my case, this is
going to be readiness
probes and healthy probes.
So if I'm doing rolling
updates on my cluster,
you're not going to
get to zero downtime
if you're not actually
checking for status
or readiness of your cluster.
So once we have that--
and then this is why I think you
need to disable direct access.
This is why I think
kubectl probably doesn't
need to point to production.
Ideally you want to
give that to admins,
and this is where I think
you hooking your CICD system.
Now those that are using
Kubernetes in production.
Do you have it wired
up to your CICD,
are you doing continuous
delivery with it?
So not the same number of hands,
and most people are confused,
they're looking for products
to Kubernetes integration.
And I look at them in my,
like what does that even mean?
What would happen there?
OK so what does it take
to integrate Kubernetes
to your CICD pipeline.
So we'll use cloud builder
here to try to make this work.
So what I want to
do is, remember
we're using git for
our infrastructure.
So ideally, I can actually
have my production
work loads was there as well.
So if we look at our
production configs
when we look at our
deployment here,
ideally any changes
that I make, we're
going to make a change here.
Actually it's at Dev right now.
Maybe we were about to launch
to service for the first time,
so we need to move
to production.
And since everything
is here, ideally I
can just set up a build trigger
to this repository as well.
So I can actually do that.
So I'm going to go
to my build triggers
and I'm going to set up
one for infrastructure,
but this time I don't
necessarily want to tag it.
Anything that gets
pushed here, I
want to have that automatically
roll to production.
So code review, push
it to production.
And we look at our
cloud builder here,
we're going to us a
slightly different one.
Here I'm actually going to
use another container image.
I'm just going to
bring in the GSU tools.
So to make this work,
I'm going to grab
a cube config from Google Cloud
Storage, put it in my workspace
so I can access it
for my next step.
Now my next step is going to
use kubectl to do an apply
on the production directory.
So ideally for every
environment that I want,
I can have a separate
build trigger just
to handle that piece.
So if this works, ideally if
I push to the master branch,
it should automatically
update the containers
in that environment.
So let's switch to production
and see what we have.
Kubectl, config,
use-context, production.
Kubectl, git pods.
Right, we don't have
anything running there.
Hopefully, good.
So let's just put a watch on
this and see what happens.
So what we need now
is to trigger a build.
Currently we have
Dev in our thing.
And I had a volunteer do a pull
request to my infrastructure.
So remove Dev image from name.
Who gave me this pull
request, raise your hand.
Do you know you're doing?
AUDIENCE: We'll see.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: OK.
So it's code review time.
OK.
Do not just click Merge.
Now I had no idea if this is
going to actually work, OK.
We were trying to test
this out before the talk
and we ran out of time.
But you got the pull request in.
Do you think this
is going to work?
AUDIENCE: I have faith.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: All
right, because they're
going to talk about you on
Twitter if it doesn't, it's
going to be your
fault, not mine.
All right, so we
have this commit,
and ideally you just do
a code review, right.
So let's see what's
inside of here.
So you're stripping this tag
and you want to use this image.
Right and go verify that
this image is even real,
is available.
So we go over here
and we find, what
is this thing, GIF maker 1.0.
That looks, 001,
looks all right.
So this looks good to me.
So I'm going to merge this.
Now my hope is, if this works,
we should trigger a build.
I'm hoping this works.
All right, so we're going to
look at our build history.
So we're going to see if
this triggers a build at all.
All right, so let's merge this.
All right, so rebase and merge.
Man.
OK, that did something.
And do we have a trigger?
Oh, snaps.
Oh, snap.
Let's see if it's
actually working.
So we're running through our
customer Cloud Builder file
for this.
If it completes, we'll
go through the steps,
we're going to copy
in a cube config,
we going to do QC still
apply, and if this
completes, what we should
see, our pods show up here.
And if is the right version,
after our health checks pass,
those should be running.
And then once they
start running,
we should be able to hit
the public service there,
so let's try that,
kubectl, get svc.
Oh we don't have a
service. so let's just
do-- oh, that's
going to take long,
but there's a trick
that we can do to make
this a little bit faster.
Kubectl, get pods,
will grab this name,
and then there's
a little thing you
can do Kubectl port-forward.
OK.
And then we'll do
8080 in my laptop
to 80 inside of that container.
And ideally we should be
able to push images into this
like we did earlier here.
We'll push those up and
if everything is working,
we get this back, and it works.
Awesome.
And with that, end
of the presentation.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]